it's become clear over the last few
hours that Kirsten now belongs to the
ukrainians it's clear also that the
Russians have withdrawn they've left the
city of Kirsten and more importantly
they've left the Western Bank of the
nepro river and so they've pulled out at
not just to the city but are pulling out
of the areas north of the city at
novakul kovka and some of the areas of
bereslav now that pull out may take some
time but undoubtedly that is what
they're doing this is a huge victory for
the ukrainians it's not only a symbolic
Victory because Kirsten was the only
significant City that the the Russians
took but it's also a military Victory
because it puts most of Crimea in range
of the Rockets and the missiles that the
ukrainians can now bring up onto their
side of the uh the river nipra however
there are problems as well the bridge
the antonovsky bridge is down the
Russians have made sure that they have
destroyed the bridge this is the main
Bridge the M14 Highway that ran through
the area and having damaged the bridge
to prevent the Russian Jews and get the
Russians have now taken sections of the
bridge down completely so that the
ukrainians cannot use it at all and that
will give the ukrainians a problem
because as they sit on the Western Bank
of the Nipper River the Russians are in
the Eastern Bank and the Russians will
be able to Shell a person with their
artillery this is exactly what they they
did in Mario Paul it's what they did in
severo Donetsk it's what they tried to
do in kharkiv and so in order to stop
that happening the ukrainians somehow
have got to push the uh the Russians at
least 30 or 40 kilometers further east
and so although the ukrainians can
attack sevastopol which is a huge prize
for them they've really got to
concentrate on either across the river
or more likely something somewhere in
the north they've got to put enough
pressure on those Russian forces to make
them withdraw further away out of
artillery range only then will curse and
City be safe
However the fact is that this is a a
great day for the ukrainians but they'll
need a few more great days like this
before the business is concluded the
fact is this war shows all the signs of
lasting for some time yet